you shared an article by Chelsea Connor
boy in the New York Times called
maternal instinct is a myth that men
created she says that the maternal
instinct is a social construct generated
and upheld by the patriarchy to impel
women to raise children and keep them
out of the workforce however part way
down you you shared a quote that was
quite revealing I think this is from her
new research on the parental brain makes
clear that the idea of maternal instinct
is something innate automatic and
distinctly female is a myth one that has
stuck despite the best efforts of
feminists to debunk it from the moment
it entered public discourse all your
thoughts on Chelsea conopy's article
Carol
well I have a lot to say uh most of it
is not good and I feel kind of bad about
that because Chelsea was probably pretty
excited about having her article in the
New York Times and she probably worked
really hard on it and I think her heart
is in the right place uh I think the
there are lots of Articles kind of like
this but this is one of the most
egregious example of this particular
kind of article maybe that I've ever
seen uh New York Times you know it's not
super surprising it was printed in that
particular Outlet
um but
so I said I think her heart is in the
right place and I guess I think that
people who write these kinds of Articles
especially from a kind of feminist point
of view are grasping at straws to find
something kind of real and biological
that will support the idea that uh women
should have equal rights and equal
opportunities you know relative to men
and well that goal may be laudable
actually I don't yeah well that goal may
be logical and we can talk about that
goal later
um what is not laudable and what really
bothers me as a scientist is the idea
that anyone believes and that
intelligent people are promoting the
idea that in order to secure anybody's
human rights whatever you think those
rights should be we have to basically
uh lie of course there's a maternal
Instinct you know we don't need to uh
kind of twist the facts of biology to
support anybody's rights we don't have
to distort reality we have to you know
we can tell the truth and fight for
people's rights those are different
things like what exists in nature is not
the same thing as what people's human
rights are we decide us humans we decide
what we want and what kind of society we
want regardless of the facts of Nature
and sort of I don't I think conflating
those two things is dangerous from many
uh perspectives but this is just also
blatantly false and pretty much
everybody knows it so it is like uh an
example of
um the emperor is actually not wearing
any clothes and nobody is saying so I
want to say so prove to me that maternal
Instinct isn't a myth that men created
okay did men so first of all it kind of
annoys me because it gives men a hell of
a lot of power men are very powerful but
you can't do that completely control how
you act we get to dictate how it is that
you interact with your children
yes and you get the rest of society to
believe something so stupid it's like
somehow you magic men have gotten us all
to believe that there is something
innate about moms wanting to care for
their children in a way that is
different and more intense than the way
that fathers do so I can you know one
way to try to prove it to you is to just
take human culture out of the mix look
at every
um mammal that is not EX exposed to
human culture well not even exposed but
look at every non-human mammal and the
females are the ones in 95 of those
mammals who uh
are the sole providers of any kind of
Parental care for their offspring of
course they have an instinct of course
that is part of being a mammal and
there's only five percent of mammals or
or even a smaller percent uh in which
the males contribute any parental care
humans are one of those species that's
part of what makes us really interesting
but males have the choice to invest in
their kids the kids can survive without
them the father they typically cannot at
least in a natural environment or an
ancestral environment uh it would be
very tough for them to survive without
their mother and uh so yes there's a
difference between men and women in the
degree to which we invest in our
Offspring not only do we have the
um comparison with non-human animals we
have mechanisms we know what some of
these mechanisms are hormonal and
neurological that contribute to maternal
care and I mean I could go on and on
about the science and there's just
nothing
bad about this you know it's great that
fathers invest in their kids it's great
that moms can have the choice to invest
less than their our partners you know
moms can go out and go to work that's
what I did I you know had somebody else
took care of my baby for the most part
during the day while I was at work I
pumped my milk but if I didn't want to
pump my milk or you know have a deep
desire it's not men didn't give me that
desire I mean that I did sort of
insulting to me it sounds like
you may have been one of the poster
children poster women for someone that
was liberated from this maternal at
least in terms of the restriction on
their ability to continue with their
career and research and stuff that
you're doing at Harvard it seems like
yeah you would be a flag waving card
carrying person for that and yet still
don't believe it
um
yeah it is something I did I didn't
really want to do that I wish I could
have stayed home
with Griffin uh who's now 13
um for much you know for a year rather
than a few months and he was close by so
I did get to
take off my shoes and run a couple
blocks to um
breastfeed him like three times a day
which was great and most moms do not get
to do that and that's really painful for
them because they have a maternal
Instinct it's painful if your breasts
are full of milk and you have to you
know have a machine squeeze it out
rather than having your kids lips suck
it out I imagine it's also quite painful
just to run if you've got breasts that
are full of milk and you're jogging down
the street it just generally it's it's
challenging
well I I also saw it but I didn't feel
the pain because I was so motivated
you're so maternally so maternally uh
pushed by the patriarchy a great
response to this uh that was done in
Colette according to this view the
parental brain is essentially a blank
slate filled with expectations
experiences chiefly dictated by social
expectations for women and men in other
words women's and men's parental brains
and Associated behaviors would be the
same with the right social mores and
behavioral expectations as he says
pretty much all uh mammals uh the men
don't have any uh male parental
Investments the claim fails to consider
that males do very little parenting in
the vast majority of animals especially
those including humans in which males
compete intensely for status as it
happens humans are among the exceptions
to this pattern men invest considerably
more in children than do the males of
our closest relatives chimpanzees and
bonobos who are uniformly deadbeats
later in the article he said brain
patterns can be used to correctly
identify whether the owner is a man or a
woman with 93 to 96 percent accuracy
have you seen this yes yes okay but that
there so can I sit just make two
responses there so one is I the other
aim of the article which I really did
think was important and it was too bad
that this particular goal got weighed
down with all this kind of crap science
um the goal was to show
the ways in which society
has
um in some ways because there are or
there are thought to be but in reality
there are these biological differences
the authors seem to think that this has
given license to men in particular to
um help to create policies and
expectations that limit women's ability
to do what they want to do whether they
want to you know what kind of parent
they want to be how uh invested they
should be in parenting so that's a good
goal right just because we have a uh
maternal Instinct doesn't mean that we
should do anything in particular it
doesn't even mean we should have kids or
that we should be the ones to stay home
with them but that's a separate Point
um from whatever the science says about
maternal Instinct so that was um thing
one thing yes the naturalistic fallacy
presuming that because something existed
in nature that it's something which is
laudable and desirable in the modern
world I wish that we could just dispense
with that entire line of argumentation
every single time that I see it I go
right okay men used to fight for
dominance physically we have laws that
stop you from punching people in the
street even if you both see the same
attractive woman in front of you right
like obviously obviously no one thinks
that this is the case my main problem
with this
war on motherhood war on the
pedestalization of mothers as mothers
and the assumption that if you are a
mother that decides to stay home and
build a family while your partner goes
to work that you've been rubed into
doing this by the patriarchy that you're
somehow a second-class citizen to me
saying you can do whatever you want yes
but if you're to say the maternal
instinct is a myth that men created the
subtext to that is if you fell for it
you're an idiot woman yes yes
that is a great uh
example about why this kind of article
that appears so often and in kind of
liberal Outlets is so damaging because
yes this is something that is natural
basically natural there's a lot of
variation in how it's going to be
expressed but there's nothing wrong with
getting you know gaining immense
pleasure from devoting yourself to
something that is natural if it gives
you pleasure and that's what you choose
and if it doesn't hurt anybody else you
know there's no reason to stigmatize
that as though you know you're just
doing what men want you to do but then
there's the issue about whether you can
tell male and female brains apart
so my understanding is that what you
just said is totally correct that human
beings scientists say can't just look at
brains
um say under a micro you know a little
area is necessarily and figure out what
um which are male and which are female
but that uh machine learning can do that
with a really high degree of accuracy
it does appear that there are
um systemic differences in the brain
that differentiate male and female
brains on average there's you know a
fair amount of overlap and variation but
we have different brains one question is
whether it is so one challenge to that
is that it's life experience that leads
to these differences you know if they
exist then it's all due to the
patriarchy and that uh that leads men
you know to behave in certain ways and
interacting socially in certain ways and
because they're you're performing
masculinity in society that performance
and the reception to that performance is
going to condition your brain to develop
uh in different ways from a woman's
brain you know and there may be there is
I think some truth to that but I don't
think there's any way that explains uh
male female brain differences on average
we also have lifetime difference is in
exposure to testosterone and estrogen
those steroid hormones also have lasting
impacts on brain organization starting
extremely early on in fetal development
so yes Society is important yes Society
you know just like we see with maternal
Instinct there's an initial difference
there that is shaped you know that
difference is then then plays out in
modern society in all kinds of ways and
if men if the patriarchy whatever you
think that is can somehow exploit female
labor maybe that happens but that
doesn't mean that this difference
doesn't exist or isn't innate in some
way I wonder if Chelsea conoboy has kids
uh based on the women that I've spoken
to who have had kids
once that uh hormone Cascade gets
released it's a hell of a ride and it's
a hell of a way for you to stop all of
the progesterone for men even you know
like Vassar pressing getting released
baby lying on the chest why is it that
when you pass a baby's head around
everyone wants to take a nice big whiff
of it like what do you think is going on
here even though that's even the women
that aren't that haven't given birth and
that maybe aren't even genetically
related that are just doing the whole
aloe parenting the modern version of
aloe parenting stuff now like yes
it blows my mind that people can be so
a ostensibly pro-female
and obviously anti-mother
that blows my mind
yeah that's I I don't even know where to
begin I completely agree with you one
thing that I do when I teach my class on
and I we get into the sex differences
part and we talk about
um sexual development like how over are
um
developmental trajectory we become male
and female and then what happens in
puberty and how the hormones work on our
bodies and on our brains
we have different they're different
aspects of our environment that are
Salient to us so men are much more
likely to stare at women's breasts and
that when they're walking down the
street or you know any any cues of
female fertility uh those vary by
culture but there are some that are
pretty standard and so I if I do look at
a woman's breasts it's out of some sort
of competition or I'm trying to evaluate
my own sexual competition is showing
Carol something like that yeah what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]